(train engine revving)
- Living in New York can feel like
you're constantly bombarded
with stressful sounds 24/7.
(cars hooting)
(alarm sounding)
So can sounds like these
(instruments tinging)
help with stress management and anxiety?
To get answers, I went to a university lab
to get hooked up to a
brain recording device.
Feels good.
And tracked my heart rate
at a sound bath in Brooklyn.
During sound baths or sound meditations
a facilitator like Mattan
Sharvit plays instruments.
(instruments humming)
(bright gentle music)
(drums banging)
(chimes chiming)
- So the idea is to really
listen to the instruments,
trust yourself and let go.
- [Narrator] For the nearly
two hour group session
Mattan told us to move
as little as possible.
That was actually easier
than I anticipated.
(instruments humming)
- There is never same feeling.
There is never the same trip.
It's always different.
- It kind of felt ominous and scary,
but then also like really grounding
and that was unexpected, but nice.
(gentle organ music)
To understand the science
behind how music affects
the brain and body,
I drove up to Yale
University in New Haven.
There I met AZA Allsop, a
musician and neuroscientist
who studies the effects
of music on the brain.
- Some of what sound baths
are actually tapping into
as well is this idea of meditation.
It's sort of getting
your mind into a place
that is more still.
- AZA and Mattan told me
that music helps us get into a
meditative state more easily.
What about music facilitates that?
- Some of it we think is
the actual physiology.
So the fact that your heart
rate is now slowing down,
your breathing is slowing down
when you have these
very long sort of tones.
- [Narrator] During my sound meditation
Mattan played tones that
lingered for a long time
and that were bright and light.
This was among like,
my lowest heart rates.
- So right now I hear a lot
of longer, higher frequencies.
- [Narrator] Some studies have
found that sounds like these
stimulate the parasympathetic
nervous system.
It's a network of nerves
that helps run involuntary
bodily functions like digestion.
When the activity of the
parasympathetic nervous system increases
blood pressure and heart rate go down
and you feel more relaxed.
During my visit, I tried out a session
of AZA's online music mindfulness study.
In his participants,
he's seeing lower levels
of perceived stress.
I was surprised that I also felt
calmer and more relaxed here,
even though the setting
wasn't as soothing as the Yoga studio.
(drum sounding)
But music can also be intense
and bring up unsettling emotions.
- The harmonics are a
little bit more dissonant.
There's a little bit more tension there.
- [Narrator] In some cases,
sounds with these qualities
can even activate the amygdala,
which is involved in our fear response.
- When we feel that emotion
we might cry or have some
sort of cathartic experience.
- AZA's brain imaging research
is trying to decode what kinds of music
can improve our mental health
and under what circumstances.
One of his initial findings
is that certain kinds of music
facilitates social connection
which can also relieve stress
and have positive health benefits.
AZA and his team hooked me up
to dozens of brain activity sensors
to test music's effects on brain activity
and how connected I
felt to another person.
I'm all hooked up.
In this case, head of
the brain function lab,
neuroscientist Joy Hirsch.
Hello.
We felt most connected
when we were listening to
harmonious music like this
and looking at each other.
That's in part because the
temporal parietal junction,
an area that helps with
social information processing
is more active.
And it's less active when
the music is dissonant.
(gentle music)
Feeling connected is important
because isolation is a
growing mental health problem.
58% of Americans say they're lonely.
That figure is even higher
among Hispanic and Black adults
for whom AZA and other experts say
there are big unmet mental health needs.
One barrier to accessing
sound meditation sessions
and their potential benefits is cost.
The other is time.
But research shows that even a few minutes
of pairing music and mindfulness can help.
(gentle music)